it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skin care
nerd and today i'm going to be talking about
how to adapt your routine as you get older
i'm turning 34 this year and i'm starting
to see some changes happen in my face and
if you're around the same age you'll
probably be noticing this as well
so i'm going to go through some of the
things that you might do to your routine
some things that you might add some things
that you might take away as you get older
if you like talking nerdy about the science
behind beauty products click the like the
subscribe and the nerdification
bell so you don't miss any videos
today's video is sponsored by foreo and i'm
going to start by talking about microcurrent
this topic really highlights one of the
things that i think is really important
when deciding what to use which is working
out exactly what you're trying to address
when you get older you start to see lots of
changes in your face and a lot of these don't
have anything to do with skin and so if you're
using skin care products to try to address these
it's just not going to work one of the
big changes is sagging and drooping and
this is to do with things under your skin
this is to do with muscle bone and fat
so you'll start to see a general volume loss and a
shift in the shape of your face and unfortunately
you can't really fix this with skincare it's
too deep for skin care to effectively address
to change this you generally need things
like fillers and surgery facelifts botox
so trying to change this with skin
care just isn't going to work very
well if you see skincare that claims
to help with sagging and drooping
it can help a little bit but skin is only two
millimeters thick so you can improve that two
millimeters but if everything underneath is
still changing then it's going to be limited
i think a lot of us are pretty uncomfortable
with these sorts of procedures they're a bit
more invasive and i know i am a complete
wuss when it comes to this sort of thing
so if you're a bit hesitant to go
into this sort of procedural route
then one of the few things that you can do at home
that will actually help is microcurrent so this
is the foreo bear it is an at-home
microcurrent device i did a video on
how microcurrent works and how to use the foreo
bear so check that out if you want more details
microcurrent can make your face look more lifted
it changes how your muscles tense up and it can
give you the appearance of more volume it
doesn't seem to have much effect on fat and
bone but it does seem to increase your muscle
volume and volume is volume you can generally
see the effects pretty immediately so the most
obvious ones are usually in your cheeks they
become more lifted and more sculpted and in
your forehead as well in general the effect
is going to be more dramatic if your face is
starting to droop a bit so if you're in your
late teens or early 20s then the effect you're
going to see is probably going to be very limited
but from your mid to late 20s onwards then you can
start to really see that effect after just using
it once you use it for only two to three minutes a
day and the effect lasts for a few days so you do
have to keep on using it to maintain the look and
the more you use it the more that effect builds up
i've seen some people say that because it's a
temporary effect it's not worth it and i disagree
i think that perspective that something temporary
something that lasts a few days isn't worth it
comes mostly from people who don't wear makeup
i think people who use makeup regularly know
that things that are more subtle things that are
temporary can have a big effect on your appearance
and microcurrent is less temporary than
makeup and it can have a more dramatic
effect that you can't really get easily
with makeup unless you are super talented
and of course because it goes deeper than skin
care it also does things that skin care can't
one thing i really like about microcurrent devices
is that you can pretty much immediately see the
sorts of effects you're going to get it's not like
something in skincare where you generally have to
wait a few months to see what's happening whereas
microcurrent you can immediately see what's going
to happen and you know what you're going to get
if you keep on using it with microcurrent devices
it's really important to stick with it if you stop
using it then the effects are going to fade and so
you have to be consistent i really like the foreo
bear because i'm not very good at being consistent
with things but this makes it so much easier
it's got a really easy charging port or you do a
stick a cable in it's a usb cable it doesn't have
like a bulky charging cradle or anything it also
has this silicone body which makes it really
easy to wipe down and keep clean and hygienic
when we're talking about the changes that happen
to your skin as you get older we can split it into
two categories intrinsic and extrinsic intrinsic
changes happen because your body functions
differently as it gets older and your skin is part
of your body these changes are largely unavoidable
the main changes we see in skin is that it gets
thinner and more fragile and you'll start to see
fine wrinkles extrinsic changes
happen because of the environment
the older you are the longer you've
been exposed to the environment
for skin the main environmental
thing that affects us is the sun
and you're probably sick of hearing it but this
is why everyone keeps on saying to wear sunscreen
the most common changes we see in skin
that's been exposed to a lot of sun
are deep wrinkles and crevices
age spots scaling and dryness
in caucasian skin about 80% of the signs of
aging that you see are because of sun exposure
with darker skin there's melanin which is
protective against uv light but we still see
lots of changes and the main changes we see are to
do with pigment so this is things like age spots
so unsurprisingly the best way to prevent these
changes is using sun protection the obvious thing
to use is sunscreen and you're looking for a
sunscreen that has high uva and uvb protection
both of these contribute to aging and so you're
looking for a broad spectrum high spf sunscreen
that you can happily wear every day one study
actually found that daily sunscreen use actually
reversed the signs of aging and i think this
goes to show that your skin is living it has
the ability to start repairing itself as long as
you protect it from getting reattacked every day
in general it's a good idea to wear sunscreen
every day when you go outside if you're worried
about these extrinsic changes in your skin
when you're indoors there's obviously less uv
uvb doesn't penetrate glass but depending
on your situation you can still get a large
amount of uva if you're close to a sunny
window every day then it is still a good
idea to wear sunscreen indoors i have
a video about working out whether or
not you need to wear sunscreen indoors
and i'll link that in the description
now when you're in a car i guess you're
technically indoors but there are
windows everywhere so it is one of the highest
exposures you can get while technically indoors
there's this really famous photo of a truck
driver where one side of his face was next to
a window the other side was on the other
side facing away from the closer window
and you can really see the difference
when you're really close to a window
i've had some people ask me about fluorescent
lights fluorescent lights can produce tiny amounts
of uv and this is especially the case with compact
fluorescent bulbs these are the windy looking ones
because of all those curves the coating inside the
light bulb that usually absorbs the uv sometimes
gets cracked and so little amounts of uv come
out but it is still a really tiny amount of uv
so if you're more than 25
centimeters away from the light
if you're more than about a foot it takes
about eight hours to get the equivalent of
just over a minute of midday sun exposure
from somewhere like sydney or melbourne
if you have a plastic diffuser over the top like
you would in a normal office fluorescent light
then you get even less uv so for the vast majority
of us that amount of uv isn't worth worrying about
if you have a photosensitizing condition like
some types of lupus then it could be significant
now one of the problems with sunscreen is that we
tend to get a lot of wrinkles near our eyes first
but sunscreen near your eyes can really sting
i've been adding eye sting into
my sunscreen reviews but i found
that some sunscreens that don't sting my eyes
will sting other people's eyes and vice versa
in general alcohol and sunscreens and chemical
sunscreens tend to sting people's eyes a bit
more one thing i found really helpful is mineral
sunscreen sticks like this one from neutrogena
sticks tend to run a lot less because they
have a lot more waxes in them they're a lot
more water resistant and so this can really help
if you want to get sunscreen around your eyes
but you don't want to risk it running into your
eyes with sunscreen it's important to remember
that it's not just your face that gets a lot of
sun exposure it's also your neck and your hands
so if you have a sunscreen that
doesn't really work for your face
you can still use it up by putting
it on your neck and your hands
and remember sun protection isn't just about
sunscreen there are other things you can do
as well so for example avoid going out into the
direct sun for too long in the middle of the day
when there's the most uva and uvb you can also
use uv protective clothing like hats and gloves
i actually keep a uv protective cardigan in
the car because a lot of the time i forget
to take it with me but also when i'm driving
i can slip on the sleeves backwards and then
put my thumbs through the thumb holes
and that protects the backs of my hands
now even if you hide from the sun
there are still those intrinsic changes
even without sun exposure your epidermis will
thin by up to half between the ages of 30 and 80
so there are lots of other things you can use in
skincare and the main one is retinoids retinoids
is always what dermatologists recommend tretinoin
in particular also known as retinoic acid or
retin-a this is the gold standard ingredient
and there's tons of research to back up its
effectiveness it can help with fine and coarse
wrinkles roughness freckles and pigmentation
it can actually make changes to the lower
layers of your skin so it can increase the
growth of skin cells in your dermis called
fibroblasts and it can increase collagen
so tretinoin is a pharmaceutical
it's usually a prescription only
drug so if you think that might be
suitable for you go talk to a dermatologist
there are also weaker versions in cosmetics like
retinol and granactive retinoid and these tend
to have less side effects if you're introducing
a retinoid into your routine be really careful
go slower than you think you have to if you
use too much too quickly you can have lots
of side effects like dryness redness
irritation and stinging i have another
video on how i personally introduce tretinoin
into my routine and that will be down below
now as your skin gets older it doesn't hold on
to water as well so it tends to get thinner and
dry out more easily it also becomes more fragile
so it doesn't stand up to trauma as well and it
doesn't heal as quickly so you'll have to treat
your skin a bit more gently so things like harsh
physical exfoliants and rough washcloths probably
won't be as suitable you'll probably want to use
less hot water in your routine as well so
hot water is really good at washing away
the natural moisturizers that your skin produces
you'll probably also want to use more moisturizer
in your routine and i think a lot of us think of
moisturizer as something that's not very active
but keeping your skin hydrated is really
important in keeping it functioning correctly
one of the changes in your skin as you get older
is that your skin doesn't exfoliate itself as
effectively it doesn't desquamate as well part of
this is that your skin turnover decreases you're
not producing skin cells as quickly but part of it
is just dehydration when your skin is dehydrated
then it doesn't exfoliate itself correctly
and so hydrating it can really help with that
now if your skin still isn't exfoliating
itself enough then you might want to add in
a chemical exfoliant alpha hydroxy acids are the
chemical exfoliators with the best evidence for
them for anti-aging they speed up the skin
turnover that slows down as you get older
they also help with other things as well they can
even out pigmentation they can decrease roughness
and they can even increase collagen
there are different levels that you
can go with with alpha hydroxy acids as well so
something that is a leave on chemical exfoliant
won't get as deep as a professional peel one of
the issues with alpha hydroxy acids is that it can
increase uv sensitivity so if you're using
these make sure you're also using a sunscreen
there are some other anti-aging ingredients
as well in particular antioxidants vitamin
c and peptides there is less evidence for
these but they could be worth looking into
depending on your situation there is a lot
of variability when it comes to the formulas
of these though so a good rule of thumb is to
look for clinical tests on the finished formula
so this is things like before
and afters and clinical studies
now if you're worried about pigment then one
important thing to consider is the depth of the
pigment most skin care especially if you're not
using drug products can only really deal with very
surface level pigment some good ingredients for
dealing with pigment are retinoids hydroquinone
vitamin c butane kojic acid niacinamide and
licorice extract with extracts be really careful
because there are lots of different types
of extracts and not all licorice extracts
will actually help with pigment so make sure you
look for a product that actually specifies that
it's for pigment if you have deeper pigment that
these skincare products aren't really helping with
or if you're not sure how deep your
pigment is then go to a professional
who can diagnose your problem and
help you out with that so they can
put you on a treatment plan that includes
stronger treatments like lasers and peels
wrinkles come from repeated movements as well
as the condition of your skin you can think
of it like a piece of leather wrinkles will
form when you fold that leather repeatedly
this is why you might have heard of preventative
botox that actually stops your face from moving as
much and so you don't get these folded in wrinkles
there are also wrinkles called sleep wrinkles that
come from sleeping on your side or on your
front so your face basically gets smushed up
and because we sleep for about a third of our
lives this smooshing can etch in a wrinkle in
our skin so for a lot of people it can be worth
it to train yourself to sleep on your back
now some people shouldn't be doing this because
there might be other reasons they're not sleeping
on their back like sleep apnea now this is way
more serious than sleep wrinkles and for some
people sleeping on your back just decreases
your quality of sleep so much that it's not
worth it it can also have drawbacks for people
who want to try sleeping on their back you
don't have to have a special pillow for this
although it can make it a bit more convenient
you can use wedge pillows or you can
use towels to try to keep your head
in one spot you can also try to use a
heavier quilt that sort of holds you in place
now for makeup i'm still working on
trying to get my concealer to sit properly
but angie from hot and flashy has tons of great
tips using a primer underneath your concealer
can really help spread out the concealer
and keep it from shifting into those lines
and this is a little bit counter-intuitive but
using less concealer can actually help as well
because then there's less stuff that can
move with things like highlighters it's
good to avoid large particles because they tend
to settle into lines and make them more obvious
so those are some of my tips for how to change
your routine as you get older do you have any
other tips let me know in the comments if
you liked the video click the like and the
subscribe you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog for more nerdy science content
thank you to foreo for sponsoring this
video and i will see you next time